hello welcome to the Godzilla woman does
a variety hour
alright again like I said this is the
especially a local the Franks red double
extra high over there we've got the
extinction soft its ghost pepper ghost
pepper all right and then from hot ones
we have the last I've heard a lot of
good things about that one and by good I
mean don't don't touch it alright so
we're going to start off with the
weakest one the weakest yeah no one's
alright takes a little bit more than two
enough I gotta know maybe maybe it keeps
it very settled well you're just waiting
for me to finish now no I'm just waiting
for something to happen
aren't we all it's got a nice flavor but
it's not like it's not super hot so I
have some entry-level stuff I guess I
think these are a little bit of spice on
the back yeah I would eat more of that I
would just like casually just put that
on the Ming's when I cook it's like a
little bit hotter than to look at your
trainer amateurs
okay this is the hotter one where these
uh these darkness that was what we just
had it okay this one there's the red hot
extra it's supposed to be the hottest
Franks has all right Frank all right
Frank let's see what you got
[Music]
let no French have some stuff called
Buffalo's it's just called buffalo sauce
right and it's hotter than there's
nothing and is it really tank no mind
you my nose is running before we started
this because I'm getting over a cold
it's pretty tame alright so which one is
this this is the extinction extinction
this is supposed to be ghost pepper
sauce
are there any mornings or me [ __ ] on
that label that tells us work peppers
sauce is made with the ghost pepper
which averages 100,000 Scoville units
hot enough to spice up anything you
desire into it keep away from anything
we are fond of especially your eyes and
your children now recommended for people
with health conditions including the
heart and respiratory issues so don't
sprinkle it on k6y they tell you to read
the way hey that's pretty good
[Music]
it's definitely the warmest one so far
don't nothing quite scary you know you
think it's reduced by the fact that we
like cooked it into the wings like do
you think I'll dice me going we should
put some on there like it's nice lime
sauce yeah if we're missing anything
maybe this one's starting to burn my
lips alone I thought the fire alarm went
off it's why I got those hiccups now
smelly I've got a mild case of a it
comes that means this ghost pepper stuff
is starting to kick in
it's not quite the worst I've ever had
because I had worse of the Matt
restaurant oh you think that's aa little
bit that stuff that we had at the
restaurant waiting yeah we have a so
anyway yeah this is not nearly as bad as
that this sure it's a little bit spicy
my like my lips are burning and I have
eight cups a little like it still like
just casually eat that I'm not sure
which well let's let's go there we're
ready to go there I don't know I just
one should we do or do you want a little
sauce on put this off pretty good but
let's put it on the hottest one we've
got so put it on one of the ghost pepper
one ism absolutely so take something
that's already like legendarily high and
then put it on something that's like all
already hot to begin to get exactly we
have our emergency I sleep about 10 out
of 10 that's like only a hundred
thousand skull though a B then that's
not that's not that bad that'd be
perfect
do we have our emergency ice cream
palette I got emergency chaos oh nice
you know what crack that open
[Music]
you open the plastic on this I'll get
the spoons it's just the way a
precaution
just wet your spoon in there that's what
God invented spoons for what are you
doing just forget this is money is don't
get it maybe it was just 20 years
removed from your humor try 30
thank God I waited dad bring on I'm just
making sure you're safe old jammer when
it's Labor Day huh they say dab it put
it on like this
give me a little a chopstick or I'm
gonna get it out of there yeah that does
look kind of it's real thing
why don't you ask Sean sure this is Sean
Evans Chris Evan Oh God
it looks like a little bit much I'm not
playing yeah that's a lot let me get
mine ready oh look it's it's eroding
it's eating them yeah that's like wow
it's not I was like I was like so all of
them I was looking at it I was like what
doesn't look like it is I want it to be
more hot all right great Cheers
[Music]
huh oh it's a little bit like a set type
of mustard being put on like sushi Bobby
doesn't it taste kind like that Bobby is
a Japanese for I'm sorry
spend the night right now all right look
at this all right here we are
see what happen now it was hot when it
hit the lip oh it's delicious actually
good stuff it is hot which is kicking in
feel like eating up well I feel it like
back in my mouth are you doing this
thing yet yeah I'm starting to feel it
creeps on you oh [ __ ] that that is like
a time delay what's the matter son oh
man forget it he's getting all red and
purple Oh vital haha it's slipping away
from you like you used to not be able to
handle this college Foreman is back
brother I'm gonna pound you all around
the rink right that didn't come out
right
alright really that's subsided with one
quick swig of soda I like it
that was good it does kicking that back
in it does keep go my nose it's around
the wings came out wonderful oh yeah I
don't think I can eat ten of those no I
actually sit down and eating a bowl of
those I would make myself so that would
be crazy at this point I still haven't
had a drink
Brook sweat and the red started crying
I turned pretty red not sweatin but I
turn really ready well I can definitely
go on not once I'm ready for this I
think I could do it too mr. salt that's
the one that's making all these
celebrity people freak out yeah like
they believed I was going on with little
discipline now yeah that one my wonders
they're playing it up I'm still thinking
I don't know I have a theory that when
you drink alcohol it kind of makes your
tastebuds sensitive sensitive
you know I'm Way less sensitive a hot
stuff know that I quit drink back you
you missed so good it's over for a year
right yeah great thanks for sharing of
authorial I've never quit anything well
why are you still on the lacrosse team
dad
okay last-minute addition Phoenix came
up with a rather controversial idea
she said what if we put all the sauces
on one wing at the same time I can hear
you giggling back there we'll start off
with Frank's red hi everybody
we've got some pranks going on no there
we go now this stuff comes out really
quick so you gotta watch it but it's the
especi eye roll it's it's very viscous
this is the extinction sauce goes
whitshire which was kind of hot I mean
it flakes but not too much though that
it would like scare me off
like I could eat like 10 11 so [ __ ] oh
my god that wing looks diabolical and I
think that about establishes dad you're
gonna ruin your insights you just spent
a year recovering and becoming super
healthy and now you're gonna just like
go back to the hospital lot my living
will is up to date
you guys get nothing if I die I get the
rest of the wings okay here we go
[Music]
I like the taste on the darks
has it has a feeling all right fine I'm
not a big fan of crap on the end or
cartilage I like that stuff
you're not dead you get nothing damn
enough to fight another day why you said
the will had nothing into them I mean
are you still filming yeah
filming the Ray I want us to watch how
you devolve we got to get that in there
too I just did a suicide bomb feel
pretty warm inside right now all warm
and fuzzy
Godzilla Mendoza senior passed away 20
18th of a wing overdose well if you're
gonna live to live life in the fast lane
you better have full coverage no wait
that's not it
she might self-checkout you'll go blind
how long have I survived it I like them
like a minute and a half
all right well I'm proud of you yeah I
think I made it I did it you did it
I feel thank me for coming up with the
talent Carol man brought to you by
abstinence oh do it all right
that stuff's not bad
[Music]
[Music]